[Musica]
desiderio
desiderio stasera
tutti parlano di desiderio
mi hanno chiamato qui mi hanno detto
parla di quelli che
sono i
desideri di un viaggiatore
ebbene
dirò qualcosa impopolare ma me la parola
desiderio proprio non piace mi viene
l'orticaria
non mi piace non la sopporto con una
parola che uso molto raramente
perché che vuol dire desidera lontano
dalle stelle
non mi piace perché
è un problema mio probabilmente è
semplicemente un problema semantico
legato alla parola stessa non mi piace
perché immaginate tutti da piccoli
abbiamo abbiamo letto la favola di
aladino
aladino trova questa lampada
la pulisce la strofina appare il genio
che almeno i miei coetanei i miei
coetanei in cui tutti ricordiamo con la
voce di gigi proietti
appare questo genio e dice puoi
esprimere tre desideri e perché è come
se il genio e poi fare esprimere tutti
desideri che vanno solo tre solo tre
desideri
mettiamo lorenzo
chiaramente al mio onomastico è legata
la notte di san lorenzo ho passato gli
anni con tutti gli amici che mi
telefonavano mi facevano gli auguri e
dicevano e quali desideri esprimerai
stasera guardando le stelle è andato in
ii con gli amici stai tv né del
torcicollo guardare le stelle niente poi
magari abbassati la testa che sentivi a
ecco l'ho visto l'ho vista e la prima
domanda che sentiva ha espresso il
desiderio
il compleanno
soffia sulle candeline
esprimi il desiderio ma perché
perché devo esprimere tre desideri
perché devo aspettare un anno per le
stelle cadenti
devo soffiare su queste candeline e
aspettare che un deus ex machina no
qualcuno dall'alto esprima realizzi il
mio desiderio
chiariamo non ho nulla contro desiderio
e allora uno dice vabbè ma tu non hai
qualcosa sì probabilmente dentro di me
uno dei desideri ma pure quello che sta
dentro di me non lo voglio chiamare
desiderio
io lo chiamo sogno
i sogni ad occhi aperti no sono un
grandissimo sognatore insomma è qualcosa
che si muove dentro ti cresce dentro e
sono è qualcosa che
cerchi di realizzare to
cioè proprio nella forma vorrei
realizzare un sogno oppure esprimo
desiderio che sono due cose distaccate e
allora
io preferisco chiamarlo sogno il sogno è
qualcosa che che so un giorno la mattina
di dicembre sta bevendo caffè guardi
fuori della finestra c'è un un raggio di
luce su un albero ai un'intuizione
qualcosa che si inizia a muovere dentro
poi la cosa più bella per iniziare ad
anela anelare qualcosa no a voler
raggiungere
qualcosa ma l'intuizione è un sogno che
già in quel momento vuole prendere forma
io sono un grande sognatore sono un
viaggiatore ma sono un sognatore per me
le cose corrispondono io sogno
leggendo libri guardo le fotografie
sogno le mappe le mappe le mappe sono
delle fucine apre una mappa e si apre il
vaso di pandora e sogno guardando le
curve altimetriche le ansie dei fiumi
sogno guardando i nomi dei villaggi
lontani
avete mai provato a leggere i nomi dei
villaggi della polonia
a cosa però ci sono stato in un sacco di
villaggi e sogni di andare a vedere
questi villaggi
se sei il viaggiatore è facile andare a
parigi mai di quel villaggio doveva
vedere se gli anziani in piazza si
riuniscono e dicono le stesse cose che
dicono a putignano
esattamente essenzialmente sì io mi
definisco un
ulisside della genia degli unici
e vago fra i miei sogni vado verso i
miei sogni perché la vedo come un azione
proattiva
considerarsi un viaggiatore
significa pure metaforicamente pure
quando sei fermo andare verso qualcosa
non aspettare il compleanno le candeline
la notte di san lorenzo il genio della
lampada
e
seguendo questo modo di fare ho
realizzato molti sogni io io ho
realizzato non il genio della lampada
che si milito dove sta lo vado a cercare
pure
come ho fatto
con i miei due motori principali
la curiosità sono curiosissimo curiosi
sono curioso come la scimmia come un
branco di scimmie lago qualunque cosa è
la volontà
come si dice qui da noi o la capa tosta
perché questo perché io ho sempre
pensato che uno deve essere artefice del
proprio destino
deve essere artefice della realizzazione
dei propri sogni
non puoi aspettare altri fattori esterni
il tempo passa e le candeline e si
spengono
perché viviamo essenzialmente in una
società in cui che già decide quello che
dobbiamo che dobbiamo essere no
abbiamo le etichette tutti tutti i
giorni 1 e piccolo va a scuola e quello
e studenti che stai per laureare
laureando cioè di laurea giovane e
brillante che sta entrando nel mondo del
lavoro quest'etichetta lunghissima che
è troppo lunga poi nel mio caso no presi
il tesserino da giornalista
buongiorno dotto scaraggi giornalista
che
facevo il fotografo e lorenzo il
fotografo
lorenzo il videomaker il regista certo
sono tutte cose che mi appartengono
lavoro faccio il reporter giro
documentari a milano fastidio queste
etichette pensate che io non so nemmeno
ogni volta che finisco i bigliettini da
visita che preparo il file da mandare al
tipografo non so cosa devo mettere come
qualifica
perché
perché essenzialmente io a 46 anni non
so trovare un'etichetta di attribuirmi
cioè io sono l'evoluzione di tutto
quello che ho vissuto
io sono solo incarnazione organica dei
miei sogni
io sono un viaggiatore mi considero un
viaggiatore perché era il mio sogno
essere viaggiato neanche perché
considerate
la cosa bella dell'essere viaggiatore
che la tua forma mentis ragiona sempre
nell'ottica del viaggio che poi è quello
che accade nella vita di tutti i giorni
no è solo che io faccio il figo che
faccio il viaggiatore di però leggo sta
roba da viaggiatore
però quando uno viaggia incontra gente
tutti i giorni impara lingue diverse
tutti i giorni viene investito da colori
bellissimi
poi è chiaro ci sono gli inconvenienti
però fanno parte del viaggio
è un'attitudine quella di vivere così
che non è un vivere alla giornata
e un essere pronto e questo faceva parte
del mio sogno e io l'ho sempre sognato
questo pensate da piccolo alla scuola
la scuola materna
mi raccontano dei vaghi ricordi
avevo tre anni fui assente qualche
giorno tornano a scuola le maestre a
lorenzo cosa hai fatto sono andato a
venezia ho visto il canal grande e ho
visto le gondole non era vero niente
0 0 che queste le maestre disse la mia
madre ma come
lui mi nel nostro figlio buone non è
normale
dieci anni io vivo a bitonto vivevo a
bitonto non solo bitontino il mio sogno
a 10 anni era andare a vedere il mare a
giovinazzo
ai però
considerate 8 km per un bambino sono
tanti presi la bicicletta 8 km 9 km
presi la bicicletta e restate
luglio agosto quando mia madre dormiva
come si dice da noi ha la controra
primis in bicicletta
andai a giovino attraversai questo su
un'impresa epica perché attraversa
questo mare di ulivi
arrivare a giovinazzo guarda il mare e
torna in dentro volevo vedere il mare
mia madre non ho mai saputo altri venti
o per esempio
da studente da buon studente ero sempre
senza soldi volevo vedere le maree di
monza michelle sono andati in autostop
lo sognavo proprio sono andati in
autostop
o quando ho fatto il giro del
peloponneso in bicicletta che pure li
ami la felicissima idea di partire ad
agosto stavano 48 gradi in peloponneso
ho portato l'abbronzatura per tre anni
l'abbronzatura dei fatti all'unci del
peloponneso
oppure dopo laureato avevo letto
hemingway hanno studiato storia volevo
fare il reporter di guerra
chiaramente cosa ho fatto sono partito
per per la guerra per i posti di guerra
sono stato come reporter in molti posti
di guerra ma pensate mio padre mi
telefonava
diceva allora ma sento una voce araba al
cellulare ma cos'è no papà e russo no
sto sto a mosca per per un viaggio
perché io continuavo a sognare di essere
viaggiatore è la summa di tutto questo
perché a un certo punto ho detto ok
allora dieci anni fa cosa vuoi fare
voglio fare il viaggiatore cosa sai fare
io so raccontare su fotografare su
viaggiare mi compro un camper dell 82
inizio a viaggiare diventerà il mio
lavoro e la gente diceva faber chi è che
non lo vorrebbe fare un fallo e tutti lo
possiamo fare in questo momento possiamo
farlo questo tutti siamo liberi di farlo
lanciai una raccolta fondi perché volevo
fare il vivi giro d'europa
io diceva la gente guardate che io sto
condividendo un sogno io condivido il
mio sogno con voi
e la gente mi ha supportato ha pagato il
mio viaggio perché la gente rifletteva
su di me i sogni
quindi io oltre a essere il mio sogno
era anche il sogno degli altri non sono
megalomane stiamo parlando chiaramente
avete capito insomma e ho fatto questo
giro d'europa tra l'altro in tutte le
cose che poi comporta perché c'è un
effetto domino
grazie al giro d'europa ho conosciuto
mia moglie valentina
è stato un viaggio straordinario
viaggiavo fatto il periplo dei 20.000 km
a 70 chilometri orari non prendevo
neanche l'autostrada tanto era inutile
andare l'autostrada per avere ata per
arrivare prima perché non arrivati prima
e
sempre ho guidato tenendo il mare sulla
mia sinistra questa costante del mare
baudelaire diceva uomo libero sempre
mera il mare
e stato un viaggio straordinario
e io mi disse il vostok
tutto questo
un giorno sarà
deve essere il mio lavoro
chiaro i detrattori va beh sì sì va bene
valuto cioè non ci sono problemi che poi
immaginate bostock vostro 100k come la
navicella spaziale di yuri gagarin
quindi io non mi allontanavo non
desideravo ad sidera va come come dire
andavo verso le stelle
e è arrivato il momento in cui questo è
diventato il mio lavoro
mi pagano per realizzare i miei sogni
detto accorciato chiaramente che ci sono
titolari però mi pagano per realizzare i
miei sogni
e qualcuno diceva dei rischi e i rischi
chiaro che ci sono i rischi se da
ulisside non ti fai negare a quell
albero maestro
non potrei mai stare qui a raccontare
come il canto delle sirene se non corri
se non corre rischi e le cose non
accadono se non ti metti un viaggio le
cose non accadono
allora mi dicono ma non hai paura certo
che ho paura una paura il motore del
coraggio però a parte il fatto che
quando vado nei posti
io sono sempre stato accolto bene perché
in ogni cultura il viaggiatore o il
sognatore era era sacro
io direi no ok
c'è da avere paura di me che sono lo
straniero quello che l'elemento esterno
invece vengo accolto dappertutto perché
probabilmente la gente ama i sogni
e allora
a questo punto
dopo
questo questa dopo circa la paura io io
chiedo sempre alla gente ok io non ho
paura ma tu non hai paura della routine
della con forgione
paura di darti degli alibi paura di
aspettare il genio della lampada paura
di aspettare il compleanno
paura di aspettare le stelle cadenti
qual è la vera paura io ho paura di non
sognare più
ho paura un giorno di guardare fuori
fuori dalla finestra come dicevo prima
non
sognare ho paura di non desiderare più
di andare in quei posti dal nome
impronunciabile
ma vale la pena correre il rischio
perché essere il proprio sogno è sempre
essere il mio sogno è sempre stata la
mia priorità è il sogno che dovevo
realizzare il mio sogno ha preso il mio
corpo
perché non era il mio corpo che portava
il sogno e lo ha portato che ne so
a vedere le nuvole danzanti sul
sull'altopiano anatolico lungo la via
della seta o os questo corpo
ha sentito il vento del polo nord sulle
falesie norvegia
tutto
parte dai sogni
essere il proprio sogno
il sogno che ha portato il mio corpo in
giro
egli diventi tu il tuo sogno
ecco perché io non desidero
io sogno io ho scelto di essere un
viaggiatore
ho scelto di essere un sognatore
ho scelto
di essere il mio sogno il mio sogno sono
io
grazie
[Applauso]